if we do forecast
in 60 years we're at 16 billion if we do
forecasts and i'm comfortable being
wrong
in 120 years right 32 billion you won't
know whether you were wrong or not i
don't care if i know why the human
species will cease to exist so because
we won't be here i'm in the insurance
business i'm in the insurance i sell
life insurance okay all right
do you know what age you're gonna die i
don't know what age i'm gonna die nobody
does nobody does but guess what it's
better off having it in case you do die
so your family is protected yeah so i
want to sit there and say okay for the
people that are using tactics to win
elections today
that's not climate change shouldn't be
the number one priority of any campaign
should it be a top 10 thing that we pay
attention to that we have to figure out
a way not even the word climate change
is not even on my priority it's what's
the plan to know what the capacity of
this you know planet is what is our
capacity we need to know those numbers
what number can we not touch